oh did you watch don't look up i did and
i thought thoughts well first of all i
thought it had potential to be a [ __ ]
classic i could tell they ran out of
money no what bro what do you mean get
this budget for the film what do you
think
700 million dollars you're off by one
zero 70 million okay okay 70 million
bucks okay how much of that do you think
they paid leo
oh that's a good i mean that's a good
question 40.
it's 30.
and wow
uh
jennifer
was 25.
okay so most of the budget went into
talent and then timothy chalamet you
know he was five yeah so call it an even
50. he said 20 hill jonah hill two throw
another five out yep uh meryl streep
another five just you know just just
chop the fives down so by the time he
came down to make a film about going to
space and all that on the head what's
his face was hellboy you know that was a
cool 500k yeah he was great didn't even
say anything so you know what's crazy is
i'm watching the movie i'm like why is
this [ __ ] so familiar and then i
realized i auditioned to be jennifer's
character the the reporter boyfriend the
first one who works station i yeah
audition for that [ __ ] i've nev you
know obviously i've not auditioned for
many things and i like laughed i was
like i would have looked like a little
boy next to her that is why they asked
me is she tall i don't know man i just
think like that dude looked a lot older
than i was
um
and i don't think i i think if i had
been casted for that role everyone would
have gone
is that
is that kid like 16.
should have grown a beard or something
for the self tape maybe yeah well i'd so
i did and but here's what's crazy is
that movie was in production for so
[ __ ] long it was supposed to come out
of uh i think 2019. because the
production got put on hold because of
covid but they're still doing auditions
and i did the self tape in [ __ ] new
zealand no way 20 20. yeah
holy [ __ ] and then uh i went in after
when we got back they were still like
auditioning for it because it was like
in limbo so i went in and i did the read
in person i started like remembering the
lines i'm like that is even crazy i can
remember this [ __ ] um you're like
reciting them as he's saying them yeah
what the [ __ ] yeah how do you know this
yeah i just rolled my eyes up in my head
you have to go on the daily route my mom
loves that show
what's happening what's happening what's
happening and then you go i don't know i
don't know
no what i did do is i said them in
unison and then i paused the film and i
ranted for an hour about how it could
have been me see this is the way i would
have played that kid exactly i think his
motivation and this is a little bit yeah
yeah no i thought it was a good movie
all my friends hated it they were all
like you know it's redditer humor it's
all just
it thinks it's way smarter than it is
like we had at the climate thing and you
know yeah but i thought it was really
funny i thought the jokes were good i
thought the acting was incredible like
leo's character was
great all the characters were great
actually jonah hill meryl streep
uh i mean they were all [ __ ] great
i think i get what your friends mean by
like reddit or humor i think so do i but
i just didn't i'm not watching it that
seriously it's a comedy so i'm watching
for the jokes i'm not watching for the
narrative or for like the
commentary on the climate crisis you
know what i'm saying yeah i'm not
because i'm smart i want to laugh i want
jokes you know i don't want to think i i
just even even like
the fact that they kept calling back to
the
whoever that was the senator or whatever
that charges them for snacks like just
that that was a reoccurring theme
that even in the end she's lying there
and they're watching the comments she's
like i just don't understand why he
would do that like that's [ __ ] it's
funny
yeah i think what made it
okay so i think what gave it like the
redditer humor feel is i think the lack
of budget
i think if those same lines were shot in
a more expensive way people wouldn't
have thought that like when jonah hill
had his like little asides like when he
had those little digs like
if the scene was set up a bit more
cinematic and then there was like this
like kind of like special like close-up
on jonah hill where he like leans into
someone and like says it and it's shot
like [ __ ] anamorphic people would
have gone
damn this is like [ __ ] funny like the
the quality is there but because they
just had to like shoot it on like one
red and like pan it around the room i
think that's what made it feel like kind
of cheap i don't know
um interesting
i i i genuinely feel like that's what
took away from it in some ways and it's
not their fault like they were trying to
work with what they had and then
i think some of the moments were
definitely improv and i think that also
made it feel like reddit or humor-ish
where it kind of felt like people
riffing and then in the edit someone's
like dude this is funny let's leave it
in and yeah i think in some way
that felt a little bit cheap too like
because i think there was probably like
a time situation where they're like uh
[ __ ] like we can't we can't really like
run through this scene like over and
over so like why don't we just hit it a
few times and you guys like go at it i
thought that like the steve jobs or like
the elon musk character you know like
the tech overlord guy i thought that was
a little bit of a miss
he didn't really
convince me it wasn't a great parody you
know like
meryl streep was supposed to be trump
or trump a trump-like president right
and like jonah hill's whole angle on
thinking his mom's hot was a play-off of
trump thinking that his daughter's hot
you know the weird [ __ ] that trump said
about his daughter
so like i thought all that stuff was on
the mark like it felt like that was good
commentary and then the
that guy's character
the weird tech guy was just like i don't
really see this isn't really real who is
like this like they're all weird but you
didn't nail the weirdness of them yeah i
i do feel like the whole like
supposed like trump person it felt super
on the nose
but i think it kind of had to be i think
another part that made it feel really
cheap and ready is like
all those [ __ ] superimposed graphics
look which ones like with the like live
chat
and then like all the it's like showing
tweets and
it's the worst i hate when they put
social media in a movie and then when
the and then when they like referred to
leo's character as like
astronomer i'd like to [ __ ] and they
like put those letters like on the
screen like ai yeah i was like yeah
yeah
you ran out of money one of the i did
laugh i did laugh at the phrase as
strong astronomer i'd like to [ __ ] i
laughed at that
peak redditor and uh
tyler perry
and who was the
kate beck was who was the female anchor
the morning show anchor yeah yeah yeah
look it up god they were perfect they
did yeah they did really well yeah
perfect
i think uh but yeah some of that [ __ ]
that's the stuff where the improv felt
like it dragged and like it there wasn't
a whole lot of intention so i honestly
feel like it would have been better if
they had like a little bit more
accuracy on some of the characters and
some [ __ ] more subdued the trump
commentary i felt like could have been
more subdued like that to me made it
feel like oh this is supposed to be like
um you know like it was trying to be a
commentary movie one of the opinions i
keep hearing is that it was good for the
first hour and then it's when they
turned the planes around or the ships
around yeah that was the when the movie
got shitty
and
i think there's
yeah i don't know there's two ways you
could view that it's like basically
literally saying that's exactly what we
do because that's kind of what the whole
movie like if you're watching it as a
commentary piece that's what it's
implying is that yeah we're at the point
now that that's what we'd do
that's what america would do is turn it
around in in
you know in
with a small chance that there's
minerals or whatever that we can mine
for profit for whatever these giant tech
overlords right
or it's just a [ __ ] movie i think
that's the part where it got mixed
reviews as well as like the film at
times felt like it didn't know what it
was trying to be
yeah there's a high
yeah what if the tech
character tech oligarch character
what if he was played by ben stiller
yeah
yeah i love it see and was jacked as
hell too yeah this is actually probably
a pretty good time to transition to the
jeff bezos picture honestly
you